I don't have to tell you things are bad. Everybody knows things are bad. It's a depression. Everybody's out of work or scared of losing their job. The dollar buys a nickel's worth. Banks are going bust. Shopkeepers keep a gun under the counter. Bunks are running wild in the street and there's nobody anywhere who seems to know what to do and there's no end to it. We know the air is unfit to breathe and our food is unfit to eat. We sit watching our TVs while some local newscaster tells us that today we had 15 homicides
我不必告诉你情况很糟糕。每个人都知道情况很糟糕。这是一场萧条。每个人都失业了，或者害怕失去工作。美元只值五分钱。银行正在倒闭。店主在柜台下藏着枪。暴徒在街上横行，似乎没有人知道该怎么办，而且这一切似乎永无止境。我们知道空气不适合呼吸，食物不适合食用。我们坐在电视机前，听着当地新闻播音员告诉我们，今天发生了15起凶杀案
and 63 violent crimes, as if that's the way it's supposed to be. We know things are bad, worse than bad. They're crazy. It's like everything everywhere is going crazy so we don't go out anymore. We sit in the house and slowly the world we're living in is getting smaller and all we say is please at least leave us alone in our living rooms. Let me have my toaster and my TV and my steel belted radios and I won't say anything. Just leave us alone. Well I'm not going to leave you alone. I want you to get mad. I don't want you to protest. I don't want you to riot. I don't want you to write to your congressman
和63起暴力犯罪，就好像这本该如此一样。我们知道情况很糟糕，比糟糕更糟。简直是疯了。就好像世界各地的一切都在变疯，所以我们不再出门了。我们坐在家里，我们生活的世界慢慢变小了，我们所说的只是请至少让我们在客厅里独处。让我拥有我的烤面包机、我的电视机和我的钢丝帘线收音机，我就什么都不说了。只要让我们独处。好吧，我不会让你们独处的。我要你们愤怒起来。我不希望你们抗议。我不希望你们暴乱。我不希望你们写信给国会议员
because I wouldn't know what to tell you to write. I don't want you to write to your congressman because I wouldn't know what to tell you to write I don't know what to do about the depression and the inflation and the Russians and the crime in the street All I know is that first you've got to get mad. You've got to say I'm a human being god damn it My life has value I want you to get up now. I want all of you to get up out of your chairs. I want you to get up right now and go to the window, open it and stick your head out and yell, I'm as mad as hell and I'm not gonna take this anymore! I want you to get up right now.
因为我不知道该告诉你们写些什么。我不希望你们写信给国会议员，因为我不知道该告诉你们写些什么。我不知道该如何应对萧条、通货膨胀、俄国人和街头犯罪。我只知道，首先你必须愤怒起来。你必须说，该死的，我是一个人！我的生命有价值。我现在要你们站起来。我要你们所有人都从椅子上站起来。我要你们现在就站起来，走到窗边，打开窗户，把头伸出去大喊：我愤怒到了极点，我再也受不了了！我现在就要你们站起来。
Get up, go to your windows, open them and stick your head out and yell I'm as mad as hell, and I'm not gonna take this anymore! Things have... I'm sorry. But I don't want to be an emperor. That's not my business. I don't want to rule or conquer anyone. I should like to help everyone if possible. Jew, Gentile, Black man, White.
站起来，走到窗边，打开窗户，把头伸出去大喊：我愤怒到了极点，我再也受不了了！事情已经……我很抱歉。但我不想成为皇帝。那不是我的事。我不想统治或征服任何人。如果可能的话，我想帮助每个人。犹太人、外邦人、黑人、白人。
We all want to help one another. Human beings are like that. We want to live by each other's happiness, not by each other's misery. We don't want to hate and despise one another. In this world there's room for everyone and the good earth is rich. And can provide for everyone. The way of life can be free and beautiful but we have lost the way. Greed has poisoned men's souls, has barricaded the world with hate, has goose-stepped us into misery and bloodshed. We have developed speed but we have shut ourselves in. Machinery that gives abundance has left us in want.
我们都想互相帮助。人类就是这样。我们想靠彼此的幸福生活，而不是靠彼此的痛苦。我们不想互相憎恨和鄙视。在这个世界上，每个人都有空间，大地是富饶的。它能供养每个人。生活方式可以是自由而美好的，但我们迷失了方向。贪婪毒害了人类的灵魂，用仇恨筑起了世界的壁垒，驱使我们走向痛苦和流血。我们发展了速度，却把自己封闭起来。带来富足的机器却让我们陷入匮乏。
Our knowledge has made us cynical, our cleverness hard and unkind. We think too much and feel too little. More than machinery, we need humanity. More than cleverness, we need kindness and gentleness. Without these qualities, life will be violent and all will be lost. The aeroplane and the radio have brought us closer together. The very nature of these inventions cries out for the goodness in men, cries out for universal brotherhood, for the unity of us all.
我们的知识使我们变得愤世嫉俗，我们的聪明使我们变得冷酷无情。我们想得太多，感受得太少。比起机器，我们更需要人性。比起聪明，我们更需要善良和温柔。没有这些品质，生活将充满暴力，一切都将丧失。飞机和收音机拉近了我们的距离。这些发明的本质呼唤着人类的善良，呼唤着普世的兄弟情谊，呼唤着我们所有人的团结。
Even now my voice is reaching millions throughout the world, millions of despairing men, women and little children, victims of a system that makes men torture and imprison innocent people. For those who can hear me I say, do not despair. victims of a system that makes men torture and imprison innocent people. To those who can hear me I say, do not despair. The misery that is now upon us is but the passing of greed, the bitterness of men who fear the way of human progress. The hate of men will pass and dictators die, and the power they took from the people will return to the people.
即使在现在，我的声音也传遍了世界各地，传给了数百万绝望的男人、女人和小孩，他们是一个让人们折磨和监禁无辜者的制度的受害者。对于那些能听到我声音的人，我说，不要绝望。他们是一个让人们折磨和监禁无辜者的制度的受害者。对于那些能听到我声音的人，我说，不要绝望。我们现在所处的苦难只是贪婪的消逝，是那些害怕人类进步的人的苦涩。人类的仇恨终将过去，独裁者终将死亡，他们从人民手中夺走的权力将回归人民。
And so long as men die, liberty will never perish. Soldiers, don't give yourselves to brutes, men who despise you, enslave you, who regiment your lives, tell you what to do, what to think, and what to feel, who drill you, diet you, treat you like cattle, use you as cannon fodder. Don't give yourselves to these unnatural men machine men with machine minds and machine hearts you are not machines you are not cattle you are men you have the love of humanity in your hearts you don't hate only the unloved hate the unloved and the unnatural soldiers don't fight for
只要人类还在死亡，自由就永远不会消亡。士兵们，不要把自己交给那些野蛮人，那些鄙视你们、奴役你们、管制你们的生活、告诉你们做什么、想什么、感受什么、训练你们、限制你们饮食、把你们当作牲畜、把你们当作炮灰的人。不要把自己交给这些非自然的人——有着机器头脑和机器心脏的机器人。你们不是机器，你们不是牲畜，你们是人！你们心中有对人类的爱，你们不憎恨，只有不被爱的人才憎恨，那些不被爱和非自然的人。士兵们，不要为
slavery fight for liberty in the 17th chapter of Saint Luke it is written the kingdom of God is within man, not one man nor a group of men, but in all men, in you, you the people have the power, the power to create machines, the power to create happiness, you the people have the power to make this life free and beautiful, to make this life a wonderful adventure. Then in the name of democracy, let us use that power! Let us all unite! Let us fight for a new world! A decent world, that will give men a chance to work,
奴役而战，要为自由而战！在《圣经·路加福音》第17章中写道：神的国就在人心中。不是一个人，也不是一群人，而是在所有人心中，在你们心中！你们人民拥有力量，创造机器的力量，创造幸福的力量，你们人民拥有让生命自由而美好的力量，让生命成为一场奇妙的冒险。那么，以民主的名义，让我们运用那股力量！让我们团结起来！让我们为新世界而战！一个体面的世界，它将给人们工作的机会，
that will give youth a future, and old age a security. By the promise of these things, brutes have risen to power. But they lie! They do not fulfill that promise! They never will! Dictators free themselves! But they enslave the people! Now let us fight to fulfill that promise. Let us fight to free the world, to do away with national barriers, to do away with greed, with hate and intolerance. Let us fight for a world of reason, a world where science and progress
给年轻人未来，给老年人保障。凭借这些承诺，野蛮人夺取了权力。但他们撒谎了！他们没有兑现承诺！他们永远不会！独裁者解放了自己！却奴役了人民！现在，让我们为实现那个承诺而战。让我们为解放世界而战，消除国家壁垒，消除贪婪、仇恨和偏执。让我们为一个理性的世界而战，一个科学和进步
will lead to all men's happiness. Soldiers, in the name of democracy, let us all unite! Athens, 399 BCE. Socrates holds a cup of hemlock, a poison that will kill him if he drinks it. And his students beg him to flee. The guards would look the other way, he could escape to Thessaly, he could continue to live. Instead he drinks. Not because he's suicidal, not because he's defeated, but to prove something that he can't prove any other way. The daemon is real, the inner voice that's guided him all of his life, the thing that tells him when he's about to screw up, the thing that knows his rational mind doesn't. It's not madness, it's not delusion, it's the most real thing there is.
将引领全人类走向幸福的世界。士兵们，以民主的名义，让我们团结起来！公元前399年的雅典。苏格拉底拿着一杯毒芹汁，如果喝下去就会死。他的学生恳求他逃走。守卫会睁一只眼闭一只眼，他可以逃到色萨利，他可以继续活下去。但他还是喝了。不是因为他想自杀，也不是因为他被打败了，而是为了证明一些他无法用其他方式证明的东西。那个“灵魔”（daemon）是真实的，那个引导了他一生的内在声音，那个在他即将犯错时提醒他的东西，那个他的理性思维所不知道的东西。这不是疯狂，不是妄想，这是最真实的东西。
That's what civilization has to be built on and what he made a career passing on to the youth of Athens. It's so real to him that he'll die for it. In his last words, I owe a cock to Asclepius, the god of healing, because death is the cure, not for life, for the illusion that we are only what we can measure, count, and define. 2,400 years later, we're still arguing about what he died for, and we just use different words now. We call it the unconscious, or intuition, or implicit memory, or predictive processing, or the default mode network. But it's the same thing, there's something in us that knows, and everything depends on whether or not we will listen. Here's the thing about human nature. We keep discovering the same truths and forgetting them
这就是文明必须建立的基础，也是他毕生致力于传授给雅典年轻人的东西。这对他来说如此真实，以至于他愿意为此而死。在他临终前说：“我欠阿斯克勒庇俄斯（医神）一只公鸡。”因为死亡是一种治愈，不是治愈生命，而是治愈那种认为我们仅仅是可以被测量、计算和定义的幻觉。2400年后，我们仍在争论他为何而死，只是现在我们用了不同的词汇。我们称之为潜意识、直觉、内隐记忆、预测处理或默认模式网络。但本质是一样的，我们内心深处有某种东西是知道的，一切都取决于我们是否愿意倾听。关于人性，情况是这样的：我们不断发现同样的真理，又不断
on purpose, and every culture finds shamans, every culture finds warriors, every culture discovers that we're multiple beings trying to coexist inside and outside of our heads, in the individual and in society. And then every culture forgets, let's talk about why. Depression, anxiety, dissociation, ADHD, even psychosis, we treat them like bugs in the code but what if they're features? Take sickle cell anemia. One copy of the gene gives you malaria resistance. Two copies kills you. Evolution kept it around because, in malaria zones, the trade-off was worth it.
故意遗忘它们。每种文化都会发现萨满，每种文化都会发现战士，每种文化都会发现我们是多个存在，试图在我们头脑内外、在个人和社会中并存。然后每种文化又会遗忘，让我们谈谈原因。抑郁、焦虑、解离、多动症（ADHD），甚至精神病，我们把它们当作代码中的漏洞，但如果它们是功能呢？以镰状细胞贫血为例。携带一个基因副本可以让你对疟疾产生抵抗力。两个副本则会让你死亡。进化保留了它，因为在疟疾流行区，这种权衡是值得的。
Depression might be the same. Researchers like Paul Andrews and J. Anderson Thompson argue that depression forces analytical thinking. When your ancestors faced complex social problems, the ones who could withdraw, ruminate, and problem solve, they survived. And the ones who stayed perpetually cheerful, they missed the danger signals. And so they're not your ancestors. They're dead. ADHD in a hunter-gatherer society, you know, you want someone who notices everything every moment, who can't ignore stimuli, who is always responding to other stimulation that other people deem as irrelevant, who's
抑郁症可能也是如此。像保罗·安德鲁斯（Paul Andrews）和J·安德森·汤普森（J. Anderson Thompson）这样的研究人员认为，抑郁症会强制进行分析性思考。当你的祖先面临复杂的社会问题时，那些能够退缩、反刍和解决问题的人活了下来。而那些一直保持快乐的人，他们错过了危险信号。所以他们不是你的祖先。他们已经死了。在狩猎采集社会中的多动症，你知道，你需要一个时刻注意一切、无法忽视刺激、总是对他人认为无关紧要的刺激做出反应的人，一个
always scanning for threats and opportunities. That's not a disorder. That's your scout, your early warning system. Anxiety, that's your risk assessor, the one who says maybe we shouldn't eat those berries or that wrestling might be a predator. Without anxious people, the tribe dies a preventable disaster. And when psychosis, you know, every culture has people who hear voices, who see visions, who experience reality differently, and we call them shamans, prophets, oracles, and they had, they heard patterns that others couldn't, and they brought
总是扫描威胁和机会的人。那不是障碍。那是你的侦察兵，你的预警系统。焦虑，那是你的风险评估员，那个说“也许我们不该吃那些浆果”或者“那阵骚动可能是捕食者”的人。没有焦虑的人，部落就会死于一场本可预防的灾难。至于精神病，你知道，每种文化都有人能听到声音、看到幻象、以不同的方式体验现实，我们称他们为萨满、先知、神谕，他们听到了别人听不到的模式，他们带来了
them back information from the edges of consciousness. There are people who have a genetic predisposition to have the indirect pathway in the brain, this mechanism that is supposed to filter out information be wider open so that they are hearing and seeing and acting on unconscious patterns that other people don't see. There is a world that is real to them and there's a world that they can show you if you listen. And the problem isn't that these traits exist, the problem is that we built a world that doesn't know what to do with them. Here's how it used to work. You know, every tribe needs warriors, they guard the boundaries of the culture, they guard the boundaries of the rules of the society,
来自意识边缘的信息。有些人基因上倾向于拥有大脑中的间接通路，这种本应过滤掉信息的机制更加开放，因此他们能够听到、看到并根据其他人看不到的潜意识模式采取行动。对他们来说，有一个真实的世界，如果你愿意倾听，他们可以向你展示。问题不在于这些特质的存在，问题在于我们建立了一个不知道如何处理它们的世界。过去的情况是这样的：你知道，每个部落都需要战士，他们守护文化的边界，守护社会规则的边界，
and they maintain order, and they say this is how we do things the rules are there to help you everything else is chaos and they're inherently conservative because they change might mean death to that system and that is what they protect and every tribe also needs shamans they cross the boundaries they go into darkness literally or figuratively they bring back new information new possibilities they say what if we tried this? They protect the future because they are guiding us towards what we could be. And the visions that an intuitive is seeing are not something that is real, yet. Warriors without shamans become rigid, brittle, dead. Cultures of warriors don't
他们维持秩序，他们说“这就是我们做事的方式，规则是为了帮助你，其他一切都是混乱”。他们本质上是保守的，因为改变可能意味着那个系统的死亡，而这正是他们所保护的。每个部落也需要萨满，他们跨越边界，他们进入黑暗——无论是字面意义上还是比喻意义上——他们带回新的信息、新的可能性，他们说“如果我们尝试这个会怎样？”他们保护未来，因为他们在引导我们走向我们可能成为的样子。而直觉者看到的幻象，还不是现实。没有萨满的战士会变得僵化、脆弱、死气沉沉。战士的文化不会
last. You know, Athens is more flexible of a society and more victorious of one and more memorable and meaningful than Sparta. Shamans without warriors become chaotic, groundless. They can go insane. A healthy tribe has both and crucially, they need each other even when they drive each other crazy. Sound familiar? Because it should.
持久。你知道，雅典比斯巴达更灵活、更具胜利感、更令人难忘且更有意义。没有战士的萨满会变得混乱、无根。他们可能会发疯。一个健康的部落两者兼备，而且至关重要的是，他们需要彼此，即使他们让对方抓狂。听起来耳熟吗？因为本该如此。
It's the dynamic that we've been tracking. You know, Freud was a kind of warrior, Jung was a kind of shaman, CBT was a warrior in depth psychology as a shaman, evidence-based practice as the warrior, and somatic mystical approaches of the shaman. The problem is that the evidence-based paradigms in this country, of the US. They're no longer scientific. People are pretending that they should be treated as something that is looking at science, but there's a million reasons why the actual systems that are supposed to safeguard science have become pseudoscientific. And the tragedy of modern psychology is that we let warriors win completely. We exiled the shamans, we over-identified with the ego, we became an
这就是我们一直在追踪的动态。你知道，弗洛伊德是一种战士，荣格是一种萨满，认知行为疗法（CBT）是深度心理学中的战士，而萨满则是以证据为基础的实践作为战士，躯体神秘主义方法作为萨满。问题在于，这个国家的以证据为基础的范式，即美国，它们不再是科学的了。人们假装它们应该被视为某种关注科学的东西，但实际上，那些本应保障科学的系统已经变得伪科学，原因有一百万个。现代心理学的悲剧在于，我们让战士彻底赢了。我们流放了萨满，我们过度认同自我（ego），我们变成了一个
empire, and we became a profit motive, and we became an overly objective and an overly literal culture. And one of the things that that does is that the profit motive is now in control of science, which it is inherently at odds with. And so now we're a tribe with no one to hear the voices at the edge, no one to knows what to do with them, no one to dream the new dreams, no one to say depression might tell us something. Because I'm talking about a societal level of these things here, but in the actual therapy room it works the same way because these things are also alive in your own head. When you say, feel the depression, where
帝国，我们变成了利润驱动，我们变成了一种过度客观和过度字面的文化。其中一个后果是，利润动机现在控制了科学，而这与科学本质上是背道而驰的。所以现在我们是一个部落，没有人去倾听边缘的声音，没有人知道如何处理它们，没有人去梦想新的梦想，没有人说“抑郁症可能在告诉我们什么”。因为我在这里谈论的是这些事物的社会层面，但在实际的治疗室里，它的运作方式是一样的，因为这些东西也活在你自己的头脑中。当你问“感受抑郁”，它在
is it in the body, what does it change? How old is it? My conceptualization, my interpretation, my analysis is not going to be as correct as someone's actual direct experience of what that feels like. And the process of them discovering why it is there is what makes them grow. Not just not feel sad, not just have the depression go down, going all the way through it and discovering the rich world that it can explain about why I am the way that I am, why I think the way that I think, what I'm actually trying to do with my life. Aldous Huxley called it the perennial philosophy, the truths that keep showing up, the same insights, but they wear different costumes. We're multiple, we're not singular. You singular. Plato believes in reason and spirit and appetite.
身体的哪里？它改变了什么？它有多久了？我的概念化、我的解释、我的分析，都不会比某人对那种感觉的实际直接体验更准确。而他们发现它为什么存在的过程，才是让他们成长的地方。不仅仅是不感到悲伤，不仅仅是让抑郁症减轻，而是彻底经历它，发现它能解释关于“我为什么是我”、“我为什么这样思考”、“我实际上想用我的生命做什么”的丰富世界。奥尔德斯·赫胥黎称之为“永恒哲学”，即不断出现的真理，同样的洞见，只是穿着不同的外衣。我们是多重的，我们不是单一的。你，单一的。柏拉图相信理性、精神和欲望。
He believes in a tripartite soul. He says, why is it that people are different? Why is it that in the same man there are disagreements when a singular entity should have a singular motivation yet men do not show up as platonic forms? Freud has the ego, the sup ego, and the id. The IFS has managers, firefighters, exiles, and self. Neuroscience says that there are multiple neural networks that are in constant negotiation, and we can feel these things and recognize them in our
他相信三分灵魂。他说，为什么人与人之间会有不同？为什么在同一个人身上会有分歧，当一个单一的实体应该有单一的动机时？然而人并没有表现为柏拉图式的形式。弗洛伊德有本我、自我和超我。内在家庭系统疗法（IFS）有管理者、消防员、流放者和自我（Self）。神经科学说，有多个神经网络在不断协商，我们可以感受到这些东西，并在我们的
cultures and in our mythology and in biography. Healing what happens through integration. You can't kill your shadow, you can't think your way out of trauma, you can't medicate to meaning. You medicate symptoms. And sometimes the symptom is something that is there for a reason that you do not need to examine. And other times it is there for a reason that you do. Direct experience trumps theory. Socrates says, know the self. The Buddha Buddha says come and see or come to believe. You know every effective therapy has this feel it to heal it and a lot of these earlier systems were a type of therapy. You know the body remembers everything. There are ancient
文化、神话和传记中识别它们。治愈是通过整合发生的。你不能杀死你的阴影，你不能通过思考走出创伤，你不能通过药物获得意义。你只能用药物治疗症状。有时症状的存在是有原因的，你不需要去审视它。而另一些时候，它存在是有原因的，你需要去审视。直接体验胜过理论。苏格拉底说，认识你自己。佛陀说，来，看看，或者来相信。你知道，每种有效的疗法都有这种“感受它以治愈它”的感觉，而许多早期的系统都是一种疗法。你知道，身体记得一切。有古老的
rituals, there are sacred dances, there is ritual movement. Reich had character armor, you know, the latest book to repackage a lot of those insights is The Body Keeps the Score or something like Eastern Body, Western Mind. It's also a fantastic book. Consciousness is bigger than the individual. The indigenous, the idea that we're part of the web, you know, Jung had the collective unconscious, but the modern neurology shows mirror neurons, shared trauma, epigenetics, inherited family shadows. And something like the Dresden experiment that showed that people who were born in the womb are still reacting to emotions that their mother felt, like hunger, that they don't remember. That's a World War II experiment, where babies who were born into a first world
仪式，有神圣的舞蹈，有仪式性的动作。赖希（Reich）有“性格盔甲”，你知道，最近重新包装了许多这些洞见的书是《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）或者像《东方身体，西方心灵》（Eastern Body, Western Mind）之类的书。那也是一本很棒的书。意识比个人更大。原住民认为我们是网络的一部分，你知道，荣格有集体潜意识，但现代神经学显示了镜像神经元、共享创伤、表观遗传学、遗传的家庭阴影。还有像德累斯顿实验，它显示了在子宫里的人仍然会对母亲感受到的情绪（如饥饿）做出反应，而他们并不记得。那是二战时期的实验，那些出生在第一世界
wealthy environment but the mother had been starving while she was pregnant all had weight problems because little switches had been turned on to get them ready for the world that they were coming into before they even were born. It said get food, you know, get too much food because it is scarce. And those switches are still there whether or not we want to look at them. You know, what's happening now, what we call in philosophy, this period would be the metamodern.
富裕环境中的婴儿，如果他们的母亲在怀孕期间挨饿，他们都有体重问题，因为在他们出生之前，一些小开关就已经被打开，让他们为即将进入的世界做好准备。它说“获取食物，你知道，获取过多的食物，因为食物很稀缺”。无论我们是否愿意去审视，那些开关仍然存在。你知道，现在正在发生的事情，我们在哲学上称之为“后现代之后”（metamodern）。
It's after the postmodern, but because we're in the middle of it or in the early beginning, we don't really know what it is and there's a lot of controversy about how to write about it. You know, we're sort of oscillating between the postmodern doubt about grand narratives, wanting to deconstruct everything, and then the sincere belief and the certainty of vast movements and grand narratives of modernism. And we're oscillating between
它在后现代之后，但因为我们正处于其中，或者处于早期阶段，我们并不真正知道它是什么，关于如何书写它有很多争议。你知道，我们有点在后现代对宏大叙事的怀疑、想要解构一切，以及现代主义中对宏大运动和宏大叙事的真诚信仰和确定性之间摇摆。我们正在
those two things. And you get a lot of weird stuff when that happens. You get an inability to analyze systems because it's sort of two systems happening at once. You get this ironic detachment between the individual and the truth. You get this, you know, radical, sincere belief at the same time as like really heightened irony and a distance from belief. And this is sort of Jung's tension of opposites, but now it's happening culturally, not just individually.
这两者之间摇摆。当这种情况发生时，你会得到很多奇怪的东西。你无法分析系统，因为这有点像是两个系统同时发生。你在个人和真理之间得到了一种讽刺性的疏离。你得到了一种，你知道，激进的、真诚的信仰，同时又伴随着高度的讽刺和对信仰的距离感。这有点像是荣格的“对立面的张力”，但现在它在文化上发生，而不仅仅是在个人身上。
We need heroic narratives from modernism, but we know, we also need to know that there are constructions which comes from postmodernism. We crave meaning and we can't turn that craving off, but we have to see through meetings, which is the postmodern. We want to believe, but we can't unsee the machinery. And there can be this third way of knowing
我们需要来自现代主义的英雄叙事，但我们也需要知道，存在着来自后现代主义的建构。我们渴望意义，我们无法关闭这种渴望，但我们必须看穿意义，这就是后现代主义。我们想相信，但我们无法忽视那些机制。并且可能存在这种第三种认知方式
that we will build. You know, there isn't, this isn't a problem to be solved. It's just an inevitable result of the last thousand years. And the increasing technological metaphors that we're able to make as technology is in this light speed. You know, real therapy has always been shamanic. You know, not in this new age like I did at ayahuasca wants kind of way, but in a real ancient way. The therapist is one who crosses between worlds, who retrieves lost parts, you know, lost parts of the tribe and people, but also lost parts of the patient in the individual mind.
我们将建立它。你知道，没有，这不是一个需要解决的问题。这只是过去一千年不可避免的结果。以及随着技术以光速发展，我们能够制造出的日益增加的技术隐喻。你知道，真正的治疗一直都是萨满式的。你知道，不是那种新时代式的“我做过一次死藤水”的方式，而是以一种真正的古老方式。治疗师是跨越世界的人，他们找回丢失的部分，你知道，部落和人民丢失的部分，但也包括个人头脑中患者丢失的部分。
They speak multiple languages at once, somatic, symbolic, and literal, and they hold space for transformation, and they have faith to know which language is needed at that time, and which language the patient needs to learn to speak. I'm not a fan of mythopoetic everything. A lot of what I do is psychoeducation. A lot of what I do is CBT. It's just that I hold that as one tool among many. And we need to bring back that kind of integration.
他们同时说多种语言：躯体的、象征的和字面的，他们为转化留出空间，他们有信念知道在那个时候需要哪种语言，以及患者需要学习说哪种语言。我不是“神话诗意一切”的粉丝。我所做的很多是心理教育。我所做的很多是认知行为疗法。只是我把它作为众多工具中的一种。我们需要带回那种整合。
You know, this is what Socrates was doing. It's what the mystery schools in Athens taught. It's what indigenous healers knew, and it's what Jungcrates was doing. It's what the mystery schools in Athens taught. It's what indigenous healers knew, and it's what Jung rediscovered. And not everything old is good, but a lot of things that are independently useful, society will reinvent. A lot of the new science can help us build newer categories
你知道，这就是苏格拉底在做的。这是雅典的神秘学校所教导的。这是原住民治疗师所知道的，也是荣格重新发现的。并非所有古老的东西都是好的，但许多独立有用的东西，社会会重新发明。许多新的科学可以帮助我们建立更新的类别
because we do need categories for mental health. We do need something similar to what is essentially the biomedical model that puts things into these categories. But one of the things that might be useful is to take the idea that modern neuroscience has discovered that there are different types of memory and that trauma is not recorded on a videotape in your head. It isn't like, you know, you're at the cookout
因为我们确实需要心理健康的类别。我们确实需要类似于本质上是生物医学模型的东西，把事物放入这些类别中。但可能有用的一点是，采纳现代神经科学发现的观点，即存在不同类型的记忆，创伤并不是记录在你头脑中的录像带。它不像，你知道，你在野餐
and a firework goes off and then you see the videotape of Vietnam play and then somebody goes, Bill, Bill, are you all right? And then you're back in the present moment. Not all trauma is recorded like a videotape. There's explicit and declarative memory. There's implicit and procedural memory, what your body knows, how to ride a bike, how to dissociate, things that you don't think about. With explicit and declarative memory, this is what happened to me. You know, CBT does work there. A lot of those things we are conscious of and a type of therapy that focuses on ego consciousness is good
然后烟花响起，然后你看到越南的录像带播放，然后有人说“比尔，比尔，你还好吗？”然后你回到了当下。并非所有的创伤都像录像带一样被记录。有外显和陈述性记忆。有内隐和程序性记忆，你的身体知道什么，如何骑自行车，如何解离，那些你不会去思考的事情。对于外显和陈述性记忆，这是发生在我身上的事情。你知道，认知行为疗法在那里确实有效。许多那些事情我们是有意识的，而一种专注于自我意识的疗法是擅长
at treating them. There's emotional memory, what you feel, your amygdala, your pre-verbal memories and also your pre-conscious emotions. Emotional memory is very important for therapy and it's one of the things that CBT misses because we feel the emotion before we're thinking about it. By the time I'm thinking about it, it's gone. I need, or my ability to deeply access it is gone. I need to change the way that a patient holds their body. I need to change the way that I reflect the emotion back and say, you looked really angry there. You know, a lot of memory is state dependent. You know things in certain states that you don't know in others, and you need to prepare somebody just because they're not dissociating or having the symptom in the room
治疗它们的。有情绪记忆，你的感受，你的杏仁核，你的前语言记忆，还有你的前意识情绪。情绪记忆对治疗非常重要，它是认知行为疗法错过的事情之一，因为我们在思考情绪之前就已经感受到了它。当我思考它的时候，它已经消失了。我需要，或者我深入获取它的能力已经消失了。我需要改变患者保持身体姿势的方式。我需要改变我反射情绪的方式，说“你在那里看起来真的很生气”。你知道，许多记忆是状态依赖的。你知道在某些状态下知道的事情，在其他状态下却不知道，你需要准备某人，仅仅因为他们没有解离或在房间里没有出现症状
doesn't mean that it's not there. It's not only the time that you can measure things. And there's also, you know, collective and transgenerational memories that are kind of older than us, that I don't think that we have complete ownership of or that we can work with in a very literal way. Sometimes we just need to feel our history, feel the journey of our people, feel the journey of our soul, of our ancestors, and that is okay. It isn't a replacement for, you know, anti-psychotics.
并不意味着它不存在。不仅仅是你测量事物的时间。还有，你知道，集体和跨代记忆，它们比我们更古老，我不认为我们拥有完全的所有权，或者我们可以以一种非常字面的方式与它们合作。有时我们只需要感受我们的历史，感受我们人民的旅程，感受我们灵魂、我们祖先的旅程，这没关系。它不是抗精神病药物的替代品。
It's not a replacement for psychoeducation when somebody doesn't know how to be in the world, but it is an important part of life And these different therapies work on different memory systems like DBT is great for relational trauma emotional memory But sometimes somebody relates fine They're just having flashbulb re-experiencing and a relational type of therapy is not the right way in for them You know EMDR or brain spotting were designed to treat acute flashback experiences EMDR or brain spotting were designed to treat acute flashback experiences. You know, extremely rigid parts of self that we were conscious of but that won't change. But they're not probably the best way to teach a relationship or a way of communicating over
当某人不知道如何在这个世界上生存时，它不是心理教育的替代品，但它是生命的重要组成部分。这些不同的疗法作用于不同的记忆系统，比如辩证行为疗法（DBT）对于关系创伤、情绪记忆非常有效。但有时某人关系处理得很好，他们只是有闪回重现，而关系类型的疗法不是进入他们的正确方式。你知道，眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）或脑点疗法（Brainspotting）旨在治疗急性闪回体验。眼动脱敏再加工或脑点疗法旨在治疗急性闪回体验。你知道，我们有意识但无法改变的极其僵化的自我部分。但它们可能不是教导关系或沟通方式的最佳方式，在
a long period of time like DBT can. You know, parts work for complex trauma is about analyzing how all of these systems respond differently at different times and that they all represent different needs that we need to integrate and we need to hold and we have to validate if we're ever going to do anything with them. The real crime of the evidence-based practice paradigm is it pretended that there was one model of therapy that could just do everything and that all therapy should be the same and then everyone got better in the same way and the better models tend to not do that. There's this meta-modern oscillation that is
很长一段时间内，像辩证行为疗法那样。你知道，针对复杂创伤的“部分工作”（parts work）是关于分析所有这些系统如何在不同时间做出不同反应，它们都代表了我们需要整合、需要保持、如果我们想对它们做任何事情就必须验证的不同需求。以证据为基础的实践范式的真正罪恶在于，它假装有一种可以做所有事情的治疗模型，所有治疗都应该是相同的，然后每个人都以同样的方式好转，而更好的模型往往不这样做。存在这种后现代之后的摇摆，它
speeding up. We can't go back to modern certainty and we can't stay in post modern paralysis. We're being forced to learn something new and how to hold this paradox, how to be multiple, how to dance between worlds is an important place for psychotherapy to sit if it wants to be relevant, if it wants to be helpful. And this is why therapy is having an identity crisis. The old certainties of CBT fixes everything, of the brain as a computer, this modern postmodern critique that nothing works, it doesn't lead anywhere. We need a metamodern therapy that is evidence-based and mystery-friendly. We need scientifically rigorous and actually scientific research methods that also can account for things that are subjective and be somatically wise.
正在加速。我们无法回到现代的确定性，我们也无法停留在后现代的瘫痪中。我们被迫学习新东西，以及如何保持这种悖论，如何成为多重的，如何在世界之间跳舞，如果心理治疗想要相关、想要有帮助，这是一个重要的位置。这就是为什么治疗正在经历身份危机。认知行为疗法修复一切的旧确定性，大脑作为计算机的旧确定性，这种认为什么都不起作用的现代后现代批判，它不会导致任何地方。我们需要一种以证据为基础且对神秘友好的后现代之后疗法。我们需要科学严谨且真正科学的研究方法，这些方法也能解释主观事物，并且在躯体上是明智的。
We need individual healing and we need systemic awareness. We need ancient wisdom and modern neuroscience. And we don't need to mistake one for the other because they're not the same thing. We're not picking sides. We're holding tensions. Robert Moore used to say of archetypes, these things want all of you, they want to become all of you, and they do, and it's your job as an adult and a therapist to hold them at bay and to relate to both. We have to be shamans and warriors. You know what actually works? It is being seen, being felt, being held, meaning making, integrating parts, feeling feelings, moving
我们需要个人治愈，我们也需要系统意识。我们需要古老的智慧和现代神经科学。我们不需要把两者混为一谈，因为它们不是同一回事。我们不是在选边站。我们是在保持张力。罗伯特·摩尔（Robert Moore）过去常说原型：“这些东西想要你的全部，它们想要成为你的全部”，它们确实如此，作为成年人和治疗师，你的工作是阻止它们，并与两者建立联系。我们必须既是萨满又是战士。你知道什么真正有效吗？是被看见、被感受、被拥抱、意义构建、整合部分、感受情绪、移动
trauma through the body, connecting to something bigger. And this means that we're not just being analyzed, we're not just trying to be understood by the therapist, we're not just trying to get through it, we're actually trying to go into the heart of it, and we're not having meaning imposed And we're not killing parts of self that are bad and we're not thinking about things We're actually feeling them and we're not just talking we're actually experiencing And we're not just getting individual fixes We're connecting to something that is larger and there's the seeds of all of these things in people who didn't quite put them together
身体中的创伤、连接到更大的事物。这意味着我们不仅仅是被分析，我们不仅仅是试图被治疗师理解，我们不仅仅是试图度过难关，我们实际上是在试图进入它的核心，我们没有被强加意义，我们没有杀死坏的自我部分，我们没有在思考事物，我们实际上是在感受它们，我们不仅仅是在交谈，我们实际上是在体验，我们不仅仅是在获得个人修复，我们正在连接到更大的事物，而在那些没有完全把它们放在一起的人身上，有所有这些东西的种子
or understand all of them. In Freud and Jung and Reich. You know, every effective therapy does some version of this. They just call it different things and they use different doors, but they're all going to the same place. And recognition that we're multiple beings in multiple types of bodies with multiple types of memory living in multiple overlapping realities Trying to learn to dance together is an important realization. It is the perennial philosophy. It's what shamans knew It's what Socrates died for that beneath all of that There is a central thing that is self-evidencing that we can just experience, but we can't really rationalize And what we keep forgetting, but we can't help but also remembering and rediscovering.
或理解它们中的所有。在弗洛伊德、荣格和赖希身上。你知道，每种有效的疗法都做这种事情的某种版本。他们只是称呼它们为不同的东西，他们使用不同的门，但他们都去同一个地方。认识到我们是生活在多个重叠现实中的、拥有多种类型记忆的、拥有多种类型身体的多个存在，试图学习一起跳舞，是一个重要的认识。这就是永恒哲学。这就是萨满所知道的，这就是苏格拉底为之而死的，在所有这一切之下，有一个核心的东西是自我证明的，我们可以直接体验，但我们无法真正合理化。而我们不断遗忘，但我们也不得不记住和重新发现。
It can't go away but it also can be pushed to the fringes of society in our worst times. You know the people running these things, health care, academia, policy, they're the last people who should be. You know in tribal terms like we gave all the power to warriors with no shamanic training. They're people who fear the unconscious, deny multiplicity, worship measurement, mistake profit for health, and confuse control for everything. And confuse understanding or analysis, diagnosis for healing. And our evolutionary history had safeguards. Shamans and warriors used to balance each other.
它不会消失，但它也可能在我们最糟糕的时候被推到社会的边缘。你知道，经营这些东西的人——医疗保健、学术界、政策——他们是最不应该经营的人。你知道，用部落术语来说，就像我们把所有的权力都给了没有萨满训练的战士。他们是害怕潜意识、否认多重性、崇拜测量、把利润误认为健康、把控制误认为一切的人。并且把理解或分析、诊断误认为治愈。我们的进化史有保障措施。萨满和战士过去互相平衡。
Elders held wisdom, you know, communities held individuals, nature held culture, and we broke all the safeguards. We let all the warriors, we let the ego run everything. We exiled shamans. We pretended that the base of the brain, the brainstem, didn't exist. And we turned elders into inconveniences, we shattered communities and we became atomized and we declared a war on nature as an externality that was unimportant and then we wonder why everyone's depressed. If you're still debating whether or not the unconscious exists or the body holds trauma or if we are multiple selves that are sort of all interacting to create this experience
长者持有智慧，你知道，社区持有个人，自然持有文化，而我们打破了所有的保障措施。我们让所有的战士，我们让自我（ego）运行一切。我们流放了萨满。我们假装大脑的基础——脑干——不存在。我们把长者变成了麻烦，我们粉碎了社区，我们变得原子化，我们向作为外部因素、不重要的自然宣战，然后我们奇怪为什么每个人都抑郁。如果你还在争论潜意识是否存在，或者身体是否持有创伤，或者我们是否是多个自我，它们都在以某种方式相互作用以创造这种体验
of cognition that is an inherently slippery thing. If emotions are real or relevant, if integration beats domination, if relationships heal, then you need to leave the field. And it's not because you're wrong, it's because you're a warrior trying to do shaman work. You may just not be able to learn something that you need to know if you're ever going to help somebody in the therapy room. You know, the baseline for real therapy is that emotions are bio-physiological processes. Trauma lives in the body. We're naturally multiple parts of self, parts of memory. And integration is the goal. And direct experience actually matters, not just logical understanding. And that mystery is real.
认知是一种本质上滑溜的东西。如果情绪是真实的或相关的，如果整合胜过统治，如果关系治愈，那么你需要离开这个领域。这不是因为你错了，而是因为你是一个试图做萨满工作的战士。如果你想在治疗室里帮助某人，你可能无法学习你需要知道的东西。你知道，真正治疗的基准是情绪是生物生理过程。创伤存在于身体中。我们自然是多重的自我部分、记忆部分。整合是目标。直接体验实际上很重要，不仅仅是逻辑理解。神秘是真实的。
You have to know that you don't know everything if you're going to have any of the curiosity that gets people better, yourself and others, and not believing this. You have to know this from experience, from practice, from intuition, from the daimon that spoke to Socrates, from sitting with thousands of hours of human suffering and transformation. And remember Socrates with the hemlock? He didn't die for that idea, he died to prove something beyond his ideas. There's a way of knowing that can't be argued, measured or proven, only lived, only trusted, only followed, even into death. And that is the diamond. It is the inner voice. It is the shamanic function. It is the thing in us that knows. But it doesn't know how or why it knows and sometimes it can't explain it.
如果你想拥有让人们好转的好奇心——你自己和他人——你必须知道你并不知道一切，而不是相信这个。你必须从经验、从实践、从直觉、从对苏格拉底说话的“灵魔”、从与数千小时的人类苦难和转化相处中知道这一点。还记得喝毒芹汁的苏格拉底吗？他不是为了那个想法而死，他是为了证明超越他想法的东西而死。有一种认知方式是无法争论、测量或证明的，只能去生活、只能去信任、只能去追随，即使是走向死亡。那就是“灵魔”。它是内在的声音。它是萨满的功能。它是我们内心知道的东西。但它不知道它是如何或为什么知道的，有时它无法解释它。
But we can recognize it when we see it and every culture discovers it, names it differently, builds practices around it, and then forgets when the warriors take over and the ego takes over and the objectivity reigns. And then it remembers and then the forgetting becomes unbearable and We are at the unbearable part right now and middle health is collapsing and the Warriors approaches are failing and the shamans are returning from Exile not to take over but to restore balance One of the dangers of this time though is that all crazy people are not shamans Only some of them, right? Like there are a lot of people who are out there talking
但当我们看到它时，我们可以认出它，每种文化都会发现它、命名它、围绕它建立实践，然后在战士接管、自我接管、客观性统治时遗忘它。然后它又被记住，然后遗忘变得无法忍受，我们现在正处于无法忍受的部分，心理健康正在崩溃，战士的方法正在失败，萨满正在从流放中回归，不是为了接管，而是为了恢复平衡。然而，这个时代的一个危险是，所有的疯子都不是萨满。只有一些，对吧？就像外面有很多人在谈论
about their trauma as this metaphor and they are being mistaken for therapists, for thought leaders, for cultural figures that are making a call back to an older way of life or the unconscious, but they're really just trauma dumping their experience through metaphor on you and people are mistaking this as this shortcut. They haven't really done their own work. And until you do your own work, until the therapist has done their own work, you can't tell them apart. This metamodern moment isn't just choosing between warrior and shaman, it's remembering that we need both and we always have and we always will.
他们的创伤作为一种隐喻，他们被误认为是治疗师、思想领袖、文化人物，他们正在呼唤一种更古老的生活方式或潜意识，但他们实际上只是在通过隐喻向你倾倒他们的创伤，人们把这误认为是捷径。他们并没有真正完成他们自己的工作。在你自己完成工作之前，在治疗师完成他们自己的工作之前，你无法区分他们。这个后现代之后的时刻不仅仅是在战士和萨满之间做出选择，而是记住我们需要两者，我们一直需要，而且我们永远都需要。
And evolution doesn't make mistakes. If depression and anxiety and dissociation, even psychosis, survive millions of years, they serve functions and they need to be understood as functions of self. Because evolution itself is an incentive structure, and to pretend that it isn't is kind of wild. It's kind of crazy. These, you know, essential functions, sacred functions even. You know, the mistake was building a culture that can't use them, that medicates them, to make us more profitable, that CBTs them, that pretends that they're bugs instead of features. And the future of therapy isn't new techniques, it's remembering why we need shamans.
进化不会犯错。如果抑郁、焦虑、解离，甚至精神病，存活了数百万年，它们就发挥了功能，它们需要被理解为自我的功能。因为进化本身就是一种激励结构，假装它不是有点疯狂。这有点疯狂。这些，你知道，基本功能，甚至是神圣的功能。你知道，错误在于建立了一个无法使用它们的文化，一个为了让我们更有利可图而给它们用药的文化，一个用认知行为疗法对待它们的文化，一个假装它们是漏洞而不是功能的文化。治疗的未来不是新的技术，而是记住为什么我们需要萨满。
And then those techniques will come from there. Things like brain spotting, things like QG brain mapping, polyvagal nerve stimulation, neuromodulation, that can use these innovations to understand how we can use modern science to interact with ancient wisdom and why we develop multiplicity, why it shows up in different philosophies, in different anthropological lenses, in different sociological lenses, in modern marketing. If advertising understands something better than psychology, there is an enormous problem with who's doing what and what they're doing it for. Let's do another cold cut
然后这些技术就会由此产生。诸如脑点疗法（brain spotting）、QG脑图、迷走神经刺激、神经调节等，这些创新可以帮助我们理解如何利用现代科学与古老的智慧互动，以及为什么我们会发展出多重人格，为什么它会出现在不同的哲学、人类学视角、社会学视角以及现代营销中。如果广告业比心理学更了解某些东西，那么谁在做什么以及他们为什么这样做，就存在一个巨大的问题。让我们再来一段快剪。
back to Vienna in 1920. Alfred Adler is walking past a church while Freud and Jung and then their disciples would be having a pissing contests, you know, up until today. Jung was trying to heal the father and Freud was trying to kill him, slash become the most perfect version, or the godfather, if you will. And Alfred Adler was doing something else entirely. He's walking past a church in his old neighborhood, and something's wrong. This should be terrifying. As a child, he ran past the cemetery that used to be by the church twice daily and his heart was pounding and certain death was chasing him. And the graveyard by the church had shaped his entire psychology. His theory is about compensation, about overcoming
回到1920年的维也纳。阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒走过一座教堂，而弗洛伊德、荣格以及他们的追随者们一直在进行着“比谁尿得远”的争斗，你知道，直到今天依然如此。荣格试图治愈父亲，而弗洛伊德试图杀死他，或者说成为最完美的版本，也就是教父。而阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒则完全在做另一件事。他走过旧社区的一座教堂时，觉得有些不对劲。这本该是令人恐惧的。小时候，他每天两次跑过教堂旁边的墓地，心跳加速，感觉死神在追赶他。教堂旁的墓地塑造了他整个心理学体系。他的理论是关于补偿，关于克服。
weakness through will, but when he goes back home as an adult there's no cemetery. And he asked the locals. He checked city records. There's maps going back a century. There's nothing. There's never a graveyard there, there never was. But the terror was real, and the running was real, but the cemetery was imagination, it was metaphor, it was a child's mind creating a concrete metaphor for an abstract fear. Just like the US had done with the Satanic panic, just like so many things that everyone does. This is what separates Adler for both Freud and Jung. He realized that our most formative memories might be complete fabrications.
通过意志克服软弱，但当他成年后回到家乡时，那里根本没有墓地。他询问了当地人，查阅了城市记录，甚至有追溯到一个世纪前的地图。什么都没有。那里从来没有过墓地，从来没有。但那种恐惧是真实的，奔跑也是真实的，但墓地只是想象，是隐喻，是一个孩子的心智为抽象的恐惧创造了一个具体的隐喻。就像美国在“撒旦恐慌”中所做的那样，就像每个人都会做的许多事情一样。这就是阿德勒与弗洛伊德和荣格的区别所在。他意识到，我们最具塑造性的记忆可能完全是虚构的。
They're not lies, they're metaphors, because the psyche doesn't record events, it records cosmology. And while Freud was hunting for a primal scene, and Jung was mapping archetypes, Adler understood there's no point in analyzing what mom or dad literally did, because what you remember might never have happened, and what might have happened might be impossible to actually remember. And the memories are emotional metaphors. The stories that the psyche tells itself about what it feels like to be alive. And so Adler developed what actually works in therapy. Not the mystical depths
它们不是谎言，而是隐喻，因为心灵记录的不是事件，而是宇宙观。当弗洛伊德在寻找原始场景，荣格在绘制原型图时，阿德勒明白，分析父母实际上做了什么毫无意义，因为你所记得的可能从未发生过，而可能发生过的事情也未必能真正被记住。记忆是情感的隐喻。是心灵对自己讲述的关于活着是什么感觉的故事。因此，阿德勒发展出了在治疗中真正有效的方法。不是神秘的深渊，
and not the analytical dissection. The stuff that CBT accidentally does right when it works. And his psychology exists because most of the things that we assume, that we associate with psychotherapy come from Alfred Adler, even though he's one of the least remembered. You know, relationships matter more than theory. That encouragement beats interpretation. relationships matter more than theory, that encouragement beats interpretation, that present choices matter more than past traumas, and that you work with people, not on them. Everyone is trying to overcome something. These were all things that Adler did long before Carl Rogers and Virginia Satir and all the people who reset them. And all those evidence-based techniques that CBT claims it invented? Adler was doing them in 1910, without worksheets, without pretending the mind was a computer,
也不是分析性的解剖。而是认知行为疗法（CBT）在奏效时偶然做对的事情。他的心理学之所以存在，是因为我们认为与心理治疗相关的大多数事物都源于阿尔弗雷德·阿德勒，尽管他是最不被铭记的人之一。你知道，关系比理论更重要。鼓励胜过解释。关系比理论更重要，鼓励胜过解释，当下的选择比过去的创伤更重要，而且你是与人合作，而不是对人进行操作。每个人都在试图克服某些东西。这些都是阿德勒在卡尔·罗杰斯、弗吉尼亚·萨提亚以及所有重塑他们的人之前很久就做过的事情。而那些CBT声称自己发明的循证技术呢？阿德勒在1910年就在做了，没有工作表，没有假装大脑是一台计算机，
just human to human, helping people rewrite their metaphors, and training other people to do it in ways that survived. That survived the cognitive and the behavioral revolution, that survived up until now. And cut to Phoenix. You know, 1970. Milton Erickson is paralyzed from polio. He's colorblind, he's tone deaf, he's sitting in his wheelchair, he's become the most influential therapist and nobody can actually imitate him. Why? Because his technique was pure intuition. It was developed from a lifetime of being trapped in a body that didn't work and he
只是人与人之间的交流，帮助人们重写他们的隐喻，并以能够存续的方式训练其他人。这些方式在认知和行为革命中幸存了下来，一直延续至今。镜头切到凤凰城。1970年。米尔顿·埃里克森因小儿麻痹症而瘫痪。他色盲、音盲，坐在轮椅上，他成为了最具影响力的治疗师，但没有人能真正模仿他。为什么？因为他的技术纯粹是直觉。它源于一生被困在一个无法正常工作的身体里，他
learned to read people like books. A graduate student walked into his office, a PhD candidate. Dr. Erickson, you know, I know you don't like smoking but I've taken up pipe smoking, you know, as I've enrolled in the program and I'll smoke outside, you know, after we meet. And Erickson doesn't like to lecture about health but instead he starts describing the awkwardness of a friend that he had that would smoke the pipe. You know, if you blew it down, he wouldn't know where it was going, and then he should have blew it up, and then it was in his face. And the guy's bored to tears as Erickson just drones on for 40 minutes. You know, the ritual of packing the pipe, tamping the pipe, lighting the pipe,
学会了像读懂书一样读懂人。一名研究生走进他的办公室，一位博士候选人。“埃里克森博士，我知道你不喜欢吸烟，但我开始抽烟斗了，因为我报名参加了这个项目，我们见面后我会去外面抽。”埃里克森不喜欢说教健康，而是开始描述他的一位抽烟斗的朋友的笨拙。你知道，如果你向下吹，你不知道烟会飘向哪里，然后他本该向上吹，结果烟全喷在脸上了。那家伙听得无聊透顶，埃里克森就这样唠叨了40分钟。你知道，装烟斗、压烟草、点火、
relighting the pipe, storing the pipe, disassembling the pipe, all of these things, he walks through how awkward they are, and how they don't really mean anything and that when you think about them they're not fun to do. And the guy, the graduate student, the PhD student doesn't realize that he's being hypnotized and slowly, methodically, Erickson deconstructs every element, you know, not attacking, just observing, that they're not, they don't really have to be attached to a central narrative. And until the student realizes, you know, later, that he doesn't actually like smoking. He liked the idea of smoking because he associated it with the serious scholar with his pipe and about maturing into academia and a persona that he's trying on.
重新点火、存放烟斗、拆卸烟斗，所有这些事情，他详细描述了它们是多么笨拙，它们其实毫无意义，当你思考它们时，做这些事一点也不有趣。而那个研究生，那个博士生并没有意识到他正在被催眠。埃里克森缓慢而有条不紊地解构了每一个元素，不是攻击，只是观察，指出它们并不一定非要依附于一个核心叙事。直到后来学生意识到，他其实并不喜欢抽烟。他喜欢的是抽烟这个概念，因为他把它与叼着烟斗的严肃学者、迈向学术界的成熟以及他正在尝试扮演的人格联系在一起。
And when he leaves and tries to light the pipe, he realizes that he can't do it anymore, but that he's still himself. And, you know, by the next session the student can't even put the pipe in his mouth. He's thrown it out. You know, I heard this guy tell that story when he was close to 80, you know, if not that old and he had been, you know, mentored by Erickson. You know, and this metaphor collapsed and he became a bigger thing. And this is what Erickson understood.
当他离开并试图点燃烟斗时，他意识到他再也做不到了，但他依然是他自己。你知道，到下一次会谈时，学生甚至无法把烟斗放进嘴里。他把它扔掉了。你知道，我听到这家伙在快80岁时讲述这个故事，如果不是那么老的话，他曾受过埃里克森的指导。你知道，这个隐喻崩溃了，他变成了一个更宏大的人。这就是埃里克森所理解的。
Symptoms aren't just problems, they're blocked creative potential. And they're the psyche trying to grow but not knowing how. They're needing a bigger container, a bigger containing metaphor. And right now our culture needs a bigger containing metaphor. You know Erickson had one patient who came in and she said, she was angry, everything was gray, it was black and white, there was no point to anything, she was going to be depressed, she had seen all of these therapists, her husband wants her to go on a trip, and it's going to be awful. And Erickson says, yes, your trip with your husband will be terrible, the airport will
症状不仅仅是问题，它们是受阻的创造性潜能。它们是心灵试图成长却不知道如何成长。它们需要一个更大的容器，一个更大的包容性隐喻。而现在我们的文化需要一个更大的包容性隐喻。你知道埃里克森有一位病人，她进来时很生气，一切都是灰色的，非黑即白，一切都没有意义，她觉得自己要抑郁了，她看过所有这些治疗师，她丈夫想带她去旅行，而这将会很糟糕。埃里克森说：“是的，你和你丈夫的旅行会很糟糕，机场会
be gray, the flight will be miserable, it will all be black and white like you're describing, everything will be an inconvenience, everything will be a line, everything will be bleak, you know, just as you expect, but that's not where you're going. On this trip you're going to wait and you're going to wait and you're going to wait and you're going to wait and you will see one thing that is not black and white. You're going to see one thing that is color and she says, how do you know? And he said, I know, you know, come back and fire me and I'll refund your money. This is what you're going to do. You're going to walk through every part of the trip and you're going to see everything black and white and then there'll be one thing that is a bright vivid color and it will
是灰色的，飞行会很痛苦，一切都会像你描述的那样非黑即白，一切都会是不便，一切都会是排队，一切都会是凄凉的，正如你所预料的那样，但那不是你要去的地方。在这趟旅程中，你会等待，你会等待，你会等待，你会等待，然后你会看到一件不是非黑即白的东西。你会看到一件有颜色的东西。”她说：“你怎么知道？”他说：“我知道，回来解雇我，我会退钱给你。这就是你要做的。你会走过旅程的每一个部分，你会看到一切都是非黑即白的，然后会有一件东西是明亮鲜艳的颜色，它会
possess you and that is what the trip is for. So come back and let me know what it is that you see." And he didn't know what she would see. He didn't know that she was gonna see a bird, that she was gonna fall in love with ornithology, that that would define the rest of her life, that would pull her out of her depression and give her a greater purpose, you know? But that color was a parrot and it broke through the depression like lightning and she becomes a different thing. She transforms her entire life. And Erickson didn't prescribe birds.
占据你，这就是这趟旅行的目的。所以回来告诉我你看到了什么。”他不知道她会看到什么。他不知道她会看到一只鸟，她会爱上鸟类学，那会定义她余下的生活，那会把她从抑郁中拉出来，给她一个更伟大的目标。但那种颜色是一只鹦鹉，它像闪电一样击穿了抑郁，她变成了一个不同的人。她改变了她整个人生。而埃里克森并没有开出“鸟”的处方。
He didn't prescribe what the thing that was colored was. He prescribed looking and he gave her a bigger container for her experience even though he didn't know what that container was. He could still sit with the uncertainty of becoming big enough to contain her uncertainty. And this is what we need in the metamonad. This is what we need now, not smaller definitions, not tighter diagnostic categories, not more precise worksheets. Bigger containers, metaphors that can hold our expanding experience as the individual
他没有规定那个有颜色的东西是什么。他规定的是“去观察”，他为她的体验提供了一个更大的容器，尽管他自己也不知道那个容器是什么。他依然能够安于那种不确定性，变得足够强大去容纳她的不确定性。这就是我们在元单子（metamonad）中所需要的。这就是我们现在所需要的，不是更小的定义，不是更严苛的诊断类别，不是更精确的工作表。而是更大的容器，能够容纳我们不断扩展的体验的隐喻，作为个体
end of society, because we're breaking out of the old containers. Nation states can't contain global problems, individual therapy can't contain systemic trauma, scientific materialism can't contain consciousness, and old stories can't contain new realities. And what we need is what Adler discovered. Our memories are metaphors so we can rewrite them. We need what Erickson knew. People aren't broken, they're stuck. They don't need fixing. They need bigger stories. And they certainly don't need you to tell them what to do, even if they're asking for that. But here's the hard part. You can't fake intuition. You can't work your way to wisdom. You can't
乃至社会，因为我们正在冲破旧的容器。民族国家无法容纳全球性问题，个体治疗无法容纳系统性创伤，科学唯物主义无法容纳意识，旧的故事无法容纳新的现实。我们需要的是阿德勒所发现的。我们的记忆是隐喻，所以我们可以重写它们。我们需要埃里克森所知道的。人们没有破碎，他们只是卡住了。他们不需要被修复。他们需要更大的故事。他们当然不需要你告诉他们该怎么做，即使他们是在请求这样做。但困难的部分在这里。你无法伪造直觉。你无法通过努力工作来获得智慧。你无法
pretend you're Ericsson if you haven't done the work. The work is ongoing, but the main central alchemy of the work is this. It's separating your own intuition from your own trauma because they come from the same part of the brain and they feel the same. When you're in flow state, both of them possess you in a way that feels authentic because trauma feels like intuition but it's not. Trauma says, danger is everywhere, you have to feel this emotion or you can't feel that one. Intuition says, feel whatever you want, walk wherever you want.
假装你是埃里克森，如果你没有下过功夫。这项工作是持续的，但这项工作的主要核心炼金术是这样的：将你自己的直觉与你自己的创伤分离开来，因为它们来自大脑的同一部分，感觉也一样。当你处于心流状态时，两者都会以一种感觉真实的方式占据你，因为创伤感觉像直觉，但它不是。创伤说：危险无处不在，你必须感受这种情绪，否则你就无法感受那种情绪。直觉说：想感受什么就感受什么，想去哪里就去哪里。
Yes, there is danger but you still are safe. And if you're in this field, student, therapist, human being trying to help, and everything looks gray, everything feels stupid and pointless, you're probably right, the system is stupid, the worksheets are pointless. But like Erickson's patient, you need to look for the bird, the thing in color, the self-evident truth that breaks through the gray and lets you help people and help yourself. Maybe it's a client who transforms despite your terrible training. Maybe it's a technique that works even though it shouldn't work.
是的，有危险，但你依然是安全的。如果你在这个领域，作为学生、治疗师、试图提供帮助的人，而一切看起来都是灰色的，一切都感觉愚蠢且毫无意义，你可能是对的，系统是愚蠢的，工作表是毫无意义的。但就像埃里克森的病人一样，你需要寻找那只鸟，那个有颜色的东西，那个击穿灰色、让你能够帮助他人并帮助自己的不言自明的真理。也许是一个尽管你训练糟糕却依然蜕变的客户。也许是一个本不该有效却奏效的技术。
Maybe it's a realization that what actually helps people has nothing to do with what you're being taught. And when you see it, trust it, even if you don't understand it, especially if you don't understand it. Because even if it scares you, because it's in those times that we're the most trapped, the most stagnated, that we develop the most powerful intuition, the only trick is not lying to yourself that you're free when you're not. Not pretending you're healed when you're actually wounded, and not making your woundedness
也许是一种意识到真正帮助人们的东西与你所受的教导毫无关系的觉悟。当你看到它时，相信它，即使你不理解它，尤其是当你理解不了它的时候。因为即使它让你害怕，因为正是在那些我们最受困、最停滞的时候，我们才发展出最强大的直觉，唯一的诀窍是不要欺骗自己说你是自由的，当你其实并不自由时。不要假装你已经痊愈，当你其实伤痕累累时，也不要让你的伤痛
this persona of self, of either victimhood or authority, like so many people in this profession have done. You're neither. You're both. And no, not mistaking your trauma for wisdom. And the first step is admitting that something's wrong. We're not home. We're lost. And Adler knew that, and Erickson knew that, and the metamonarch moment knows it. And so many people right now don't. We need bigger containers, bigger stories, rooms for all of our parts to dance. Not because it's easy, not because it's necessary, because the old containers are breaking and
成为你的人格，无论是受害者心态还是权威心态，就像这个行业里的许多人所做的那样。你两者都不是。你两者都是。不要把你的创伤误认为是智慧。第一步是承认出了问题。我们没有回家。我们迷路了。阿德勒知道这一点，埃里克森知道这一点，元君（metamonarch）时刻也知道这一点。而现在有太多人不知道。我们需要更大的容器，更大的故事，让我们的所有部分都能起舞的空间。不是因为它容易，不是因为它必要，而是因为旧的容器正在破碎，
we can't build new ones, or if we don't build new ones we'll drown in fragments. And that's what makes you a good provider, not following protocols, not measuring outcomes, but holding space for the bigger story to emerge and being the midwife to metaphors, even if you don't know what's being born, especially then. You know, people on the edges hear voices and the body does keep the score. And you know, there is a perennial philosophy that is perennial and it keeps coming back
如果我们不建造新的容器，我们就会淹没在碎片中。这就是让你成为一名优秀提供者的原因，不是遵循协议，不是衡量结果，而是为更大的故事浮现留出空间，并成为隐喻的助产士，即使你不知道正在诞生什么，尤其是在那种时候。你知道，处于边缘的人能听到声音，身体确实会记录一切。你知道，有一种永恒的哲学，它是永恒的，它不断回归，
because it's true, but it's not true like two plus two equals four. It's true like the sun rises true. It's true like children need love true. It's true like don't feed your infants water. You know, true like we are all going to die and we have to deal with that because we do. True. You know because that energy goes somewhere if we don't deal with it. It's the kind of true that you can't prove. You only know it and you live it and you have to pass it
因为它真实，但它不是像“二加二等于四”那样的真实。它像“太阳升起”那样真实。它像“孩子需要爱”那样真实。它像“不要给婴儿喂水”那样真实。你知道，像“我们终将一死，我们必须面对这一点”那样真实，因为我们确实会死。真实。你知道，因为如果我们不处理它，那种能量就会流向别处。这是一种你无法证明的真实。你只能知道它，活出它，并且你必须把它
on to those who are ready to hear. The future of therapy is ancient and the healing that we need is what we've always known and the truth that can't be killed because it was never born. And it can't even really be spoken. Or maybe it just can't be explained. Maybe it can't be taught. It can only be felt. It just is like the diamond and like the sunrise and like the voices at the edges that are calling all of us home. Dull roots with spring rain Winter kept us warm, covering Earth in forgetful snow Feeding a little life with dry tubers Summer surprised us Coming over the storm-burger sea
传递给那些准备好倾听的人。治疗的未来是古老的，我们需要的是我们一直以来所知的疗愈，以及那种无法被杀死的真理，因为它从未出生。它甚至无法真正被说出。或者也许它只是无法被解释。也许它无法被教导。它只能被感受。它就像钻石，像日出，像边缘那些呼唤我们所有人回家的声音。枯萎的根系伴随着春雨，冬天让我们保持温暖，用遗忘的雪覆盖大地，用干枯的块茎喂养微小的生命，夏天让我们惊讶，越过风暴肆虐的大海，
With a shower of rain We stopped in the colonnade And went on in sunlight Into the Hothgarden And drank coffee and talked for an hour Been gar kinder rassen, stamm aus Letternes Deutsch And when we were children staying at the Archduke's, my cousin's He took me out on a sled and I was frightened He said, Marie, Marie, hold on tight and down
伴随着阵雨，我们在柱廊下停住，走进阳光，进入温室，喝着咖啡，谈论了一个小时。我们是德国人，来自立陶宛。当我们还是孩子住在表亲大公家里时，他带我出去坐雪橇，我很害怕，他说：“玛丽，玛丽，抓紧了。”然后我们冲下山，在那里你感到自由，我读了
We went in the mountains, there you feel free, I read Much of the night and go south in the winter What are the roots that clutch? What branches grow out of this stony rubbish? Son of man, you cannot say or guess, for you know only A heap of broken images where the sun beats And the dead tree gives no shelter The cricket no relief and the dry stone no sound of water only There is shadow under this red rose
大半个夜晚，冬天去南方。什么根系在抓紧？什么枝条从这堆乱石中长出？人子啊，你无法说出或猜到，因为你只知道一堆破碎的意象，阳光在那里暴晒，枯树不提供庇护，蟋蟀不提供慰藉，干石没有水声，只有这红玫瑰下有阴影。
Now I'll show you something different from either your shadowed morning striding behind you or your shadowed evening rising to meet you I will show you fear in a handful of dust Fresh wet de wind De high mat zu Many rich kind Woveless dew You gave me higherths first a year ago, They called me the Hyacinth girl. Yet when we came back, Late from the Hyacinth,
现在我将向你展示一些与你身后大步走来的阴影早晨或迎面而来的阴影夜晚不同的东西。我将向你展示一把尘土中的恐惧。你一年前第一次给了我风信子，他们叫我风信子女孩。然而当我们回来时，从风信子花丛中迟迟归来，
God in your arms, full in your hair, wet. I could not speak and my eyes failed, I was neither living nor dead, And I knew nothing looking into the heart of life The silence, oh the lid I smell Madame so-so stress, famous clairvoyant had a bad cold Nevertheless is known to be the wisest woman in Europe With a wicked pack of cards He has said she is your card, the drowned Phoenician sailor
怀里抱着花，头发上沾满花瓣，湿漉漉的。我无法说话，双眼失明，我既非活着也非死去，看着生命的中心，我一无所知。寂静，哦，盖子。我闻到……马丹·索索斯特里斯，著名的预言家，患了重感冒，尽管如此，她仍被认为是欧洲最聪明的女人。带着一副邪恶的纸牌，他说她是你的牌，溺水的腓尼基水手。
Those are pearls that were his eyes, love Here is a bella donna, the lady of the rocks, the lady of situations Here is the man with three staves and here the wheel And here is the one-eyed merchant and this card Which is blank is something he carries on his back Which I am forbidden to see, I do not find the hand man Fear death by water, I see crowds of people walking round in a ring Thank you if you see dear Mrs. Iquathone Tell her I bring the horoscope myself
那是曾经是他眼睛的珍珠，爱。这是贝拉唐娜，岩石夫人，处境夫人。这是拿着三根权杖的人，这是命运之轮。这是独眼商人，而这张空白的牌是他背在背上的东西，我被禁止观看，我找不到那个被吊着的人。恐惧死于水，我看到人群在绕圈行走。谢谢，如果你见到亲爱的伊夸索内夫人，告诉她我自己带了星座运势。
One must be so careful these days Unreal City Help! I'm not going to take it anymore! I'm mad as hell! I'm not going to take it anymore! Unreal city, under the brown fog I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna take it anymore! I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna take it anymore! I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna take it anymore! I'm mad as hell and I'm not gonna take it anymore!
这些天必须非常小心。虚幻的城市。救命！我再也受不了了！我气疯了！我再也受不了了！虚幻的城市，在褐色的雾气下。我气疯了，我再也受不了了！我气疯了，我再也受不了了！我气疯了，我再也受不了了！我气疯了，我再也受不了了！
I had not thought the way I fed and downed So many sighs, short and infrequent Were exceeded And on so many sides, short and infrequent, we're exhaled Each man fixed his eyes before his feet Float up the hill and down King William Street To where St. Mary Woolnoth kept the hours with a dead sound On the final stroke of nine, there I saw one I knew And stopped him crying, Stetson you were
我没想过我喂养和吞下的方式，如此多的叹息，短暂而不频繁，被超越了。在如此多的方面，短暂而不频繁，被呼出。每个人都把目光固定在脚前，漂浮着上山下山，沿着威廉王街，走到圣玛丽伍尔诺斯教堂用死寂的声音报时的地方。在九点的最后一声钟响时，我在那里看到了一个我认识的人，拦住他喊道：“斯泰森，你曾
with me in the ships at my lay that corpse you planted last year in your garden has it begun to sprout will it bloom this year or has the sudden frost disturbed its bed or keep the dog far hence that's friend to men, Or with his nails he'll dig it up again. You, hypocrite lector, Monsamblable mon frère. The care she sat in like a burnished throne, Glowed on the marble where the glass held up by standards, wrought with fruited vines From which a golden cupid unpeeped out
和我一起在船上，在那次战斗中，你去年种在花园里的那具尸体，它开始发芽了吗？今年会开花吗？还是突如其来的霜冻扰乱了它的床？或者让狗离远点，那是人类的朋友，否则它会用爪子把它再挖出来。你，伪善的读者，我的同类，我的兄弟。”她坐的椅子像一个磨光的宝座，在玻璃支撑的大理石上闪闪发光，上面装饰着果实的藤蔓，从中一个金色的丘比特探出头来，
Another hid his eyes behind his wings Doubled the flames of seven-branch candelabra Reflecting light upon the table As the glitter of her jewels rose to meet it From satin cases poured in rich profusion in vials of ivory and colored glass, unstoppered lurked her strange synthetic perfumes, ungwent powdered or liquid troubled, confused,
另一个把眼睛藏在翅膀后面。七枝烛台的火焰加倍，将光反射在桌子上，随着她珠宝的闪光升起迎接它，从缎面盒子里倾泻而出，在象牙和彩色玻璃瓶中，拔掉塞子，潜伏着她奇异的合成香水，软膏粉末或液体，困扰着，混乱着，
and drowned the scents in all, disturbed by the air that freshened from the window these ascended and fattening the pro-launch candle flames flung their smoke into the lacquer carrier stirring the pattern on the coffered ceiling hugh sea wood fed with copper burned green and orange framed by the colored stone in which sad light a a dolphin swam above the antique mantel was displayed as though a window gave upon the sylvan scene the change of villimal by the barbarous king so rudely forced yet there the nightingale filled all the desert with invulnerable voice and still she growled And still the world she sees Chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug, chug The brush her hair spread out in fiery points Glowed into words that would be Savagely still
淹没了所有的气味，被窗户吹进来的新鲜空气搅动，这些香气升腾，使烛火更加旺盛，将烟雾喷向漆器，搅动着方格天花板上的图案。巨大的海木用铜喂养，燃烧着绿色和橙色的火焰，被彩色石头框住，在那悲伤的光线下，一只海豚在古董壁炉上方游动，就像一扇窗户对着森林场景，菲洛梅拉被野蛮的国王粗暴地强迫，然而夜莺在那里用不可侵犯的声音填满了整个沙漠，她依然在歌唱，世界依然在注视。哒，哒，哒，哒……（重复的拟声词）她梳理头发，散发出火红的点点，闪烁成野蛮而静止的词句。
My nerves are bad tonight Yes, bad Stay with me Speak to me Why do you never speak? Speak, what are you thinking of? What thinking? What? I never know what you are thinking, think. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我今晚神经很不好。是的，很不好。留下来陪我。跟我说话。为什么你从不说话？说话，你在想什么？想什么？什么？我永远不知道你在想什么，想。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。